invité du 78 à présent de ce 20 novembre
Jacques Costille bonsoir vous êtes le
vice-président de l'Association
française de recherche sur la trisomi 21
secrétaire général également il y a de
jours se déroulait la journée nationale
de la trisomi 21 alors à ne pas
confondre avec la journée mondiale du 21
mars on en parlera d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure avec des événements que vous
préparez déjà du côté du département des
ivelines mais déjà expliquez-nous à quoi
sert ce rendez-vous cette journée
nationale qui fêtait son 10e
anniversaire cette Ann
alors cette journée nationale a été m en
place par les trisom21 France dont le
siège est un à Saint-Étienne le siège
national et donc c'est une association
qui a surtout pour but de de venir en
soutien scolaire aux enfants attant 2021
est-ce qui n'est pas tout à fait les
mêmes missions que votre association à
l'Association française de recherche sur
la trisei21 est complémentaire et vous
organisez régulièrement des événements
d'ailleurs sur l'agglomération on va
revoir quelques images pendant que que
nous parlons pour pour récolter des
fonds on refait un point sur la maladie
déjà tout d'abord en introduction la
trisomie 21 c'est la cause la plus
fréquente de retard mental concrètement
la por la personne porteuse de trisomi
21 porte 47 chromosomes au lieu de 46 et
cela entraîne des dysfonctionnements
comment cela se caractérise ça se
caractérise cela dépend des des
personnes chaque personne étant
différente euh on voit que les jeunes
filles
ou jeunes femm et ont un meilleur
parcours scolaire que que que que que
les les personnes du sex masculin ça
c'est évident après moi j'ai mon fils
qui m'a fait des des crises deonner
pendant quelques années là ça va mieux
depuis un mois et demi difficile à gérer
mais d'autres ne vont pas les faire donc
voilà ils sont tous
différentsec père de famille concerné he
par cette trisomie 21 et ce qu'on
constate aussi aujourd'hui c'est que
l'espérance de vie des personnes qui
sont porteuse de trisomi 21 augmente oui
ce qui est plutôt une bonne chose de
voir cette espérance de vie augmenter
pour autant est-ce que la société est
adaptée pour s'occuper de ces personnes
dont l'âge augmente alors il y a deux
points
1907 l'âge de de vie d'espérance de vie
éta de 7 ans maintenant on arrive plus
vers 75 70 75 ans
ensuite prise en charge par la société
ça dépend comment la société le perçoit
quand vous avez des des des professeurs
euh dans dans des émissions euh de radio
qui en court terme on cour terme ce sont
des poisons pour leur
famille c'est des mot for effectivement
vous faites référence à cette cette
interview de Jean dididier Vincent
neurologiste le 5 octobre dernier qui
est déclaré sur France Inter vous l'avez
dit les trisomic sont est un poison dans
une famille ça c'est des propos qui vous
ont choqué qui vous ont Attin blessé pas
que moi toute la toutes les familles qui
ont des enfants portants d'attinte de
tr21 ont été très choqués et ont
demander à cette personne de revenir un
peu sur ses sur ses propos parce que euh
un poison c'est quand même quelque chose
quoi ça c'est une signification dans
dans le dictionnaire et je crois pas que
la société avancera avec des personnes à
qui ont la faculté de et la facilité de
pouvoir aller dans de telle émission et
tenir de tels propos nous parents on est
plus rarement invité merci t F 78 m'
invité mais que ces gens parlent en
notre nom en
plusjà nous nous parlons déjà en tant
que parents au nom de nos enfants
pratiquement parce qu'ils ont pas tous
la capacité de de langage et que ces
personnesl viennent pratiquement
insulter h cette catégorie de pas une
catégorie
c'est personne vraiment c'est c'est
c'est ça nous a tous touché quoi et sur
la question de de la prise en charge je
reviens sur les sur les personnes qui
sont atteintes de trisomi 21 aujourd'hui
plus de la moitié de ces personnes
dépassent les 55 ans est-ce que ça pose
des problématiques nouvelles de prise en
charge est-ce que la société y répond
bien en tout cas est en bonne voie pour
y répondre disons que pour le moment
vous vous le vivez comment vous vous
inquiétez pour la suite pour la prise en
charge de de votre fils par exemple
alors un personnel je
me c'est une question de person après
euh c'est pas un sujet qui me préoccupe
pour la bonne raison c'est que même dans
la population en général quand des
parents décèdent il y a toujours des des
problèmes j'ai connu une jeune fille une
jeune femme quand elle a perdu sa sa
mère elle a commencé à faire
une comment dire je sais
plus bien
elle a eu une maladie qui s'est générée
et quand elle a perdu son père ça a
repris et et donc c'est toutes les
populations qui sont touché par la perte
d'un membre de sa famille que ce soit
les parents ou ou grands-parents même
pour vous il n'y a pas de différence que
pour moi il y a pas de différence atint
ou non trisomi 21 mais je m'excuse de
d'avoir merci merci déjà de de témoigner
d'être venu sur ce plateau parler
notamment de votre expérience et vécu en
tant que que père concerné par cette
trisomie 21 on peut évoquer la recherche
également où on est elle la recherché le
but de votre association de vrai pour
cette recherche il y a eu justement
c'est un petit peu une coïncidence à
hasard du calendrier une équipe de
chercheurs de l'Université de Washington
qui est parvenu à corriger le défaut
génétique concernant cette maladie vous
avez pris connaissance de cette étud
j'imagine c'est quelque chose qui qui
justement vous donne de l'espoir euh
sûrement qu' il y aura de l'espoir mais
ça reste bien sûr à confirmer et c'était
sur des pas sur des personnes ni des
souris c'était sur vraiment euh
une une une étude faite sur
des ils ont réussi justement à enlever
cette cellule ce chromosome sciuméraire
ce chromosome en trop justement qui
caractérise la trisomie 21 la recherche
aujourd'hui avance suffisamment
vite cette expérience Mme alors
actuellement il y a deux protocoles de
de
thérapeutique en cours une en Espagne et
une qui a
commencé au mois de septembre en France
euh
avec le le GCG composé qui un composé
qui est dans trouve dans le T vert et
qui va agir sur un gène de du chromosome
21 qui s'appelle le Dirk 1 et qui
améliore le cognitif la première ça
c'est vu sur les souris il y a eu
l'année dernière un premier essai en
Espagne qui était très positif et donc
la com missission européenne a financé
une deuxème étude en en Espagne h et en
France
euh en France c'est le professeur Touren
du CHU de Saint-Étienne qui est en
charge cette étude et donc il y a 6 si
CHU dans le sud de la France où des
personnes atteintes de 2021 vont
recevoir euh un médicament élaboré en
Suisse qui est différent de celui qui
est en Espagne et euh on aura les
résultats de ces études il y a des
recherches qui se poursuivent et et vous
devrez vous aider vous récolter des
fonds régulièrement et la recherche
continue à avancer juste très brièvement
pour conclure 23 mars ce sera la journée
mondiale cette fois-ci de la trisomie 21
et vous allez organiser un colloque un
rendez-vous sur Versailles oui à
colocque à versaill euh comme tous les
ans depuis 2005
euh date où on a créé le premier coloque
de21 qui a été reconnu par l'OMS et par
l'ONU en novembre 2011 donc le 21 mars
et la Journée mondiale de la tribune 21
et votre rendez-vous aura lieu le 23
mars le 23 mars par que le 21 estant un
jeudi donc on essaie de faire
d'organiser les colloques le le samedi
pour avoir un maximum de personnes et
euh et donc
bien je pense que ça sera sur le thème
sera sur basé sur l'éducation h et euh
parce que l'éducation ça fait
parti de la priorité euh fondamentale
pour les personnes de d'atteind notre
2021 et donc même si on soutient la
recherche médical l'éducation est
également une priorité et vous aurez
aussi l'occasion de revenir sur ce
plateau pour nous en parler justement
plus longuement merci Jacques Costille
donc vice-président et secrétaire
général de lafrt c'est la fin de cette
édition du 78 rendez-vous sur notre site
Internet pour revoir tous nos reportages
toutes nos archives n'oubliez pas les
réseaux sociaux pour laisser vos
commentaires bien sûr je vous retrouve
demain en direct à partir de 18h avec de
nouveaux invités un point complet sur
l'actu du département de 5 eniveline à
Versailles